[Music]
hey what's up on today's show
i have my good friend and radio host ken
coleman talking about
work that matters talking about
parenting being
dads how we don't know what we're doing
what we still carry from our own fathers
and so much more
stay tuned
[Music]
i'm glad to have you man hey i'm glad to
hang out with you man i always enjoy
hanging out with you you're my you're my
desk mate we sit three to four feet away
from each other that's kind of fun and i
know
and this is cool what most people don't
know
is we record the john d'alone show in
the ken coleman
that's not true it's studio it's studio
but it's been ken coleman studio for
like several years now
nah it's been dave ramsey's massive
complex with some really awesome studios
where ken gets to play every day
that's right uh that's how that works
but yeah man you and i both glad to have
you on this side of the desk man oh man
listen i'm so glad to be here i'm so
proud of you man i mean you've come in
i mean talk about changing worlds and
just jumping into live broadcasting and
taking
it out live man you're doing such good
you're helping so many people you know i
mean i've been
i've been watching it you know this
whole ramsey personality thing and this
whole
content development thing and helping
people it's really unique
and it's unique because of the content
because of the audience because of the
person who's kind of driving it and it's
been really fun
yeah to watch you come in and man there
are so many hurting people
and it's just unbelievable how you're
just loving on people and helping people
man so
it's been fun to watch and uh you know
we
we're very different people but we share
a lot of the same values yeah
and we love people yeah man you know
what i mean yeah so it's really cool
to be here man this is fun so what i
like to do on the show we have
interviews
is get behind the guy
okay right oh boy and there's something
cool going on so before we get in there
i want you to
to tell everybody and hey here's the
thing
for the listeners here we we write books
we um put out
content we put out shows we put out a
lot of books here and here at ramsey
solution and
they sold millions and millions of books
dave has
dave has yet rachel has christy wright
has
um but there's a lot of buzz on your new
project
yeah we're all working so tell me about
what in the world you're doing with this
brand new book that's coming out
well the title pretty much describes it
from paycheck to purpose
and the sentiment is simply this there
is this dominant world view
that views work as this thing we do to
live
right right if we enjoy it for a little
bit
that's gravy um but we work to live
basically take care of the basics
if there's a little left over for some
memories on vacation things are like
that
then that's great and i just don't
believe that's the case and neither does
ramsay solutions and we're really coming
at it from a very different world view
we're flipping it and we basically
believe
that you live to work now that just
freaked a lot of people out so i'm gonna
explain that because it's not exactly
like it sounds okay if i said you were
created to work
it would feel yuck but if i said you
were created to contribute i think you'd
start to go okay
i'm in i'm in so basically what i
believe is is that
we can just break down the human race
when it comes to purpose to two
major areas relational purpose
and professional purpose i say
relational purpose first
on purpose because we are created to
connect
right first and foremost so you and i
have purpose
in our relationships in our particular
relationship roles
husband father son friend
teammate on and on and on and on but we
also have professional purpose and what
i mean by that is
i think it's really obvious that we all
long to make a difference in the world
and so we do that in our relationships
so relational purpose and professional
so i'm helping people realize
hey there's more to work
than the nine to five the 401k
there is real purpose whether you're a
plumber
a professor it doesn't matter if you're
a missionary
or you are a nuclear physicist all
work can be and should be
honorable that's the whole point that's
everything i believe the whole show's
about so the idea is that
this isn't working for worth that's all
about us
it's about working to contribute that's
about everybody else so when
a teacher shows up and whether she has a
bad day or not but she does a really
good job yeah
she may feel like she had a really
crappy day but she made the difference
in the life of a second grader in ways
that she may never
know there's purpose in our work it's
about
showing up to give yourself away so i
say this very simply you were created to
fill a unique role in your work you are
needed that means you're valuable
and that means you must do it somebody
needs you to show up and be the best
version of you to use the talents that
god gave you
to actually do work that creates a
result that makes other people's lives
better
so i'm sitting there either i got laid
off
after the crazy last few years and i've
just cobbled together 17 different gigs
trying to make it work
i'm just sitting at home collecting a
check i am
you and i just hosted the other another
radio show a little while ago together
um a martyr i'm just gonna sit here in
this dead-end job because it's in the
town that i'm comfortable in or that my
wife is comfortable under my husband
whatever what do you what you just said
is profound and i want all the listeners
to get that and i have a list of
questions we're going to talk about but
we're already off
list and we're at question number one
yeah that's what the book is about that
yeah that's it how do you find that work
how do you find it what do you do
and then well then how do you get there
that's what the book is about
but so i i bet i've applied
to a thousand jobs in my life i got
addicted to applying for jobs because i
thought
that the cure to my
lack of feeling like i was contributing
to anything like i was making the money
that i
felt i was entitled to which is a whole
other nonsense i gotta it's for another
show
but i kept thinking that my my
completion
was somewhere out in another job and
what you just said was
all work is honorable it's gonna look
it's gonna it's gonna be me what am i
gonna bring to this thing
and i'm gonna stop beating up on the
external and i gotta deal with the
internal yeah it's not about your salary
it's about the significant contribution
you make you know
whether you're making a median salary in
the united states for a teacher sixty
thousand dollars but i
dare you to find more more valuable
significant people in the workforce than
teachers who craft young people
you know and and so the idea here is is
that when you begin to see
that there's a reason why at some point
in your life no matter where you're from
what
politics you ascribe to what your
spiritual experiences what country you
live in
some point everybody lays awake at night
and says why am i here
well where's that coming from like
nobody has to teach a kid to say
no nobody has to teach a kid to ask
a million questions and nobody ever
teaches you
hey at some point at three in the
morning when you're awake ask yourself
why am i here
or what should i do in my life am i
right yeah so
that to me is a soul craving a soul
craving
to be significant now you are
significant you're significant as your
human being and you were created in the
eyes of god so you're significant
but there's a soul craving to be
significant for somebody else
that's what i'm saying and i think a way
to do that
is through your work it's not all about
your work
that's why i said it's relational
purpose and professional purpose
you're a student of history so how do we
get here to where my life is all about
me because what you're saying is right
it's when
i when i work with people who are
struggling mental health if i can get
them to just shift the perspective that
your life's about service and if
somebody can get there
it's game changer that's it that's right
that's right exactly when i can get a
husband and a wife to have a
competition to see who can serve each
other the most yeah
you talk the entire family system
changes right now
what happened where did we go sideways
because we this is wired into us
you see primates picking bugs off each
other in the way you know
in the wild where did we and i'll just
say the united states where do we get
sideways and say no
this is about me i can solve me yeah i i
want to
i want to say that i don't think this is
an american problem but we we grow up as
americans and we hear rugged
individualism so
the roots of of the rugged individualism
statement is the answer to this question
okay so i don't think it's an american
thing i think it is a
i think it is a prosperity thing i mean
when you talk about countries that are
that are that are prosperous so yet
third world countries
i've been privileged to be in the
poorest parts of haiti
i've been privileged to spend time in
the jungle
of africa where there's no electricity
yeah you don't see this kind of stuff
over there
you just don't and so what has happened
is over time
in history there's the natural human
inclination to progress
and to make progress so it's okay to
want
to accomplish all right well when when
we
saw commerce begin to modernize
and this is a i'm trying not to give a
long winded answer no that's what i'm
asking i know you're a history guy well
the historical context is you go from
this colonial era
to now we go to more of a modern
commerce era
so as money and commerce became more
about
stuff as opposed to livelihood so for
instance
we were solving for lunch and now we're
solving for which couch do we want so i
know kelly's back there she's my fellow
history nerd
uh i grew up on little house on the
prairie so to illustrate what i'm saying
there was a point in american history i
can't speak to the world history but in
american history there's a point where
where work was about eggs yeah food and
you didn't get
dollars and cents as much commerce was
new
okay you just look at the country of
america so we took it 1776 is when they
go
we're independent but there was no
commerce there wasn't this money system
so
i don't want to completely nerd out but
over time when we begin to see
modernization of commerce and i can get
more
stuff whereas before it was all about
livelihood in the basics now it became
about stuff
well you stick the opportunity for
humans to progress
and it's stuff that makes my life more
convenient my life more luxurious
there's where it all comes from so then
now work became
less about the craft and it became about
accumulation
getting more stuff yeah because the the
silversmith and the blacksmith
like they they did the craft not because
it was passion
right it was we gotta live and if i go
do
this many horseshoes i'm gonna get
chickens and eggs gotcha well then when
commerce comes in it's just the natural
human i hate to say it but it is the
human condition when you introduce
commerce
so then work slowly becomes about
accumulation of
money we still have the basic needs that
the blacksmith
and the little house and the prairie
people had but now it's like well the
more of this money i get i can do more
than just provide
so work became over time a utilitarian
function
to live first then to live better
to live really really good yeah and we
got twisted on it so it all became that
now the last piece on this
then then the uh and because of ramsey
solutions people go think i'm up to this
but this is the truth
in the 50s the pell grant came out this
is post world war ii
so the pell grant comes out and higher
education is starting to become a thing
they made it accessible for people and
the federal government didn't have
anything to do with all those veterans
coming home nothing to do let's sit them
back and train them
so then the pell grant became popular
the federal government went hmm we can
actually make money off of this
and here comes sally may here comes the
federal student loan program
so now it became a marketing message hey
you really want to be successful you
want a different life
for your kids than you had on the
assembly line fred
maude send your kid to college and it
became a marketing message that the only
way to success
real success monetary stuff success
is through higher education that was the
fuel already on top of the fire that's
my take
i was coaching somebody the other day
and they made a statement they said hey
i'm struggling with parenting this is a
private call
struggling with my kid and
they made a statement by the way i've
known since
this that since my kid was little
they'll have a job with the name on
their shirt
so there's no illusions here and i said
whoa whoa whoa
that's okay and the parent was like yeah
i know it's okay it's great
i'm excited for it it's something
they're passionate about whatever but
just the idea that we've got to
delineate that
yeah that there's some sort of hey just
so you know we're not dealing with full
firepower here and i want to say man the
smartest guy i've ever met in my life is
gus menendez who fix any car on planet
earth well things on that number one
um that's okay if that's true we don't
know if that's true for that father to
assume that and that's what he's doing
is he's fallen into the class system
it's a class system and it's based on
economics
and that's where all of this became a
thing where work was about a rat race
and it became about status not
significance and i'm preaching
significance
and again let me be clear yeah because
you've asked me this before
when i say significance i don't mean
proving that you are significant of
course of course i'm saying making a
significant contribution in the sense
that you were born with talent
yeah you were born with things that fire
your soul up stuff that fires you up
makes me want to fall asleep vice versa
right right
we have a unique contribution to make
and work's got to be about more than
income it's got to be about impact as
well that's what i'm saying
therein lies the title of the book from
paycheck
to purpose do we need a paycheck yes yes
we need income
but i think people want more than income
yeah
absolutely so we're going to show them
seven stages in the book where we unpack
a very clear path
or how we a figure out what is what are
all the different types of work
that are very significant to me
and because it's significant to me it'll
be significant to others what is that
role that
that dream job or multiple dream jobs by
the way then how do we get there so
anyway
uh it comes from a deep longing that i
just know that this whole
nine to five race and this whole i need
more stuff
work has been corrupted to say once you
look at these
diseases of despair you look at the
we're paying it we're paying a cost i'm
glad to see somebody
get into the into the missional part of
work somebody's got to deal with it and
i think now i've got we got a generation
of young people who's putting their
entire
identity in identity and work it's true
but i will tell you we see that with the
millennials but i really am encouraged
by what i'm seeing out of ginseng yeah
they're saying i'm out man
well they're crazy relationship because
they're the digital they're the kids
that grew up with a phone their whole
life they don't even know what it's like
to not have a smartphone in their pudgy
little hands but they're sick of it
they are sick of it they're sick of it i
love it and by the way that's the whole
human race we long for a relationship
all right let's take a quick break we'll
be right back on dr john maloney's show
[Music]
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to betterhelp.com for 10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
delony take care of yourself start today
all right ken so we got your pitch out
of the way tell us about
ken how many brothers and sisters you
got where are you from mom and dad tell
us about you yeah
uh one brother okay jamie is three and a
half years younger than me so it's just
the two boys y'all friends
we are yeah closer now than we were as
kids simply because i was
three and a half years older but four
grades the way that he felt
and so it was fourth grade so imagine so
you're never in the same school yeah
like so like he's a he's an eighth
grader and i'm a senior
you know and so there's just a hundred
years yeah it really is so a lot of
separation but no
no no animosity but as we've gotten
older now
very close that's similar to me and my
brother yeah mom and dad
the real life ken and barbara and barbie
yeah and barbara coleman high school
sweetheart that's the real name their
real name ken and barbara
yeah yeah no yeah if you see my dad he's
like five six he's not anything
resembling the kendall nor am i uh as
everybody now knows
so um pastor's kid
um never lived a day when my dad wasn't
a pastor
started a church straight out of bible
college
he did yeah he drives from chattanooga
tennessee
with my mom in a 72
volkswagen bug and they started church
with six families
in point pleasant west virginia a town
of 5 000 people
and it was the county seat
so i was actually high school had 4 000
kids in it yeah
yeah and i was born in a really small
town in west virginia we moved from
that small town uh when i was 12
to the hampton roads area virginia so it
was like going from
literally mayberry to what i thought was
a metropolis which was uh it was about
six hundred thousand people in that area
so it was a real dramatic change yeah it
was a big city for sure
uh and so that's kind of the i'm giving
you the quick childhood but i mean
you know great family so the the we all
know the
the jokes about preachers kids yeah was
that you
no if i know what joke you're telling
well so here's my hypothesis tell me if
i'm right
i think there are preachers kids i don't
get myself in trouble here
i think there are preachers kids who do
one of two things
if they've got i don't want to do that
we won't even go there
yeah i don't mind i'm not the blessing
no it's not that i'm saying there's
when parents when people see have their
parents are
in some sort of you know helping
profession
and kids see a consistency they see
oh my dad and my mom are who they say
they are every day of the week
they don't just put on a show on this
day of the week and i guess this is for
teachers and cops kids and
ministers kids whatever it's when they
see
a different parent performing over here
over here there's that cognitive
dissonance in the kids
and there ends up being some sort of
something doesn't feel right um
and then so i know folks who have been
pastors or teachers or cops or whatever
you want to say and
and they've got they are consistent they
are and their kids bear that out
and then there's those that struggle
yeah it's my story in that i
i not lost a love of the church or
ministry i don't have a bitter taste in
my mouth my mom and dad weren't perfect
but
certainly that's not my experience i was
very involved even
up into college i'd come back and help
out in a very small church by the way
small church and um but your dad was who
he said he was huh
yeah that's awesome legit sold out
so where did you come up with this idea
that
you wanted to help other people you and
i have talked about this offline just
sitting at the desk
losing your job is one of the most
psychologically devastating events a
person can go through
yeah i shared this data with you studies
show when a business says
that we don't want you yeah when you're
out of work
up to six months they say that the
trauma the emotional trauma on a human
being is the same as losing a loved one
right
i was struck by that yeah you weren't as
surprised but it's pretty big deal so
who
who who put that where's that where does
that burr in your heart come from
like i want to get in the middle of that
type of drama and pain
yeah well um and help people where it
comes from
it wasn't that developed obviously but
my father in ministry my mom and dad
loved people
they loved people that small church
ministry there wasn't any money in it
yeah they struggled they loved people so
i always saw
a model of loving on people spiritually
my dad loved history and you know when
you've got a parent
whether it be a mother father who's into
something big time oh yeah i think a kid
goes one of two ways
you either totally reject it like what
or you totally
just eat it up and i don't know if i
could prove that out
no it's it's i think it's right i just
fell in love with history now one of the
things i now know later on is my parents
couldn't afford to take us to disney
world
so we went to battlefields so i'm like
climbing up on redoubts and the fact
that i even know what a redoubt is makes
me
so pathetic but it's where they would
build the mounds
to fire their guns and so they're still
there my dad would go hey that's where
the
revolutionary war readout was but then
uh back then
and then the civil war used it and i'm
like okay this is awesome
and i'm running around in a field but i
think it's a big time deal because my
dad said a major battle happened here do
you know what i mean
i knew what the battle of bull run was
before i was 10. nobody knows what that
is
and the fact that we live in an
ecosystem that would suggest oh
you know what you really should have
been learning about dancing mice
dancing
i don't even know if he's a dog what is
goofy but right like that's
that's the way we tell our story so
bottom line is this history thing starts
to weigh
in on things so i've got parents who are
sold out to love it on people
in a spiritual context yeah i've got
this unbelievable
appreciation for history so all i ever
read about and hear about are men and
women who do great things
that starts to weigh in on you you go my
mom and dad love on people
they're making a difference in people's
lives these men and women that i read
about are awesome because they did
things that changed people's lives
right whether it be political or science
or thomas edison or anything
all those accomplishments had human
beings on the other end of the
accomplishments
serving other people sure einstein yeah
edison
electricity alexander graham bell i mean
we we forget that all these great
accomplishments have people
on the other end of it that really
benefit from talent that's the whole
point so
i think that was a big part of it and
then my dad was very political
so the last piece was public service
but it was in the context of politics i
won't go into politics
but you take all three of those elements
ministry
history and politics it i don't know
that it could have
it just was like a giant rushing river
that led me to
serving people but i thought it was
going to be politics i thought it was
going to be public service making policy
influencing policy that would make
people's lives better gotcha and then
there was a shift when
in in my late 20s and and
it became you know many years later
broadcasting
but i didn't know it i just knew that i
wanted to make people's lives better
but i couldn't articulate that oh i
don't know many 20 year olds that can oh
no i'm even giving you like 16. i just
knew man i'm supposed to go i'm supposed
to go do public service i felt i was
called into politics at 16
but i know what it was going to look
like of course i mean you're 16.
i thought i was supposed to be in a
metal band and a pro baseball player at
16.
you know you would have been the real
life like not real life he is a real
person
you would have been like a bo jackson if
you pulled that off bo jackson was like
the first person to be amazing and
and be a star in two major pro leagues
if you would have pulled off
rock star and baseball player been
incredible
still wouldn't have been bo jackson
doesn't matter if you were a major
leaguer
and you did concerts on the weekend
incredible
neither of those worked out thanks for
kicking me while i'm down though i
appreciate that
okay so getting back to contribution
thinking about our families so you and i
at the end of the day
i don't want to to minimize what we do
but one of the things we do is we give
advice for a living
yeah and
man there's sometimes the tools that
make us successful at our jobs
and i've worked with doctors and lawyers
and preachers
the tools that make you successful at
your job often
melt the people in our houses right our
relationships at home
and so how do you balance being the guy
that america calls when they're
struggling with something
and then the guy at home how do you
shift and navigate
hey all these people are asking for my
advice and your 14 year old is just like
hey how would you shut up old man
and yeah let me you know what i mean how
do you balance that well i haven't i
haven't done a good job of it
and you know that what does that mean oh
i just i'm recently awakening to the
fact that i've been parenting my kids as
a coach because i love sports
yeah you know so i i i played sports my
whole life
i always matriculated to the coach who
was kind of the tough love yeah
i knew my coach loved me yeah but he'd
bust my butt and he was tough and i
responded well
to people who pushed me yeah um
and then i'm learning about fear of the
fear of a father
what's that mean well it's the fear of
the mother
too but for me what it means is is that
you have this
dream of being a parent which i did and
our journey was very different and
all over the place as you know and you
finally become a parent and you just
want to invest and pour into these kids
that you love
so much you can't even possibly
articulate it
and you go along and then they don't
turn out
maybe the way you expect it or they
don't do things you expected
and it's just the normal rhythm we're
not talking about major stuff here and
you begin to get controlling because
you're like well i'm afraid that they
may not do this i'm afraid that they
don't
and and then then you combine that
with this i can coach
i can i can show you i can teach you
i can convince you i can influence you
to do what i know is best for you
yeah and i'm passionate about it yeah i
got bigger muscles than you like
i can make you do this and so what
happens is it
i do believe it it started in the right
place from the heart yep
but then it comes out of the heart
starts making yeah this is this is
really not
uh science but i'm gonna describe this
way it comes from the heart
somewhere it gets up here into the brain
before it comes out my mouth and it
turns into coaching and controlling and
it's
and and it's been hard because
you can't parent with platitudes
it's really easy for me to do that yeah
i'm just being really wrong
i've had to stop being a coach and i got
to start being a dad and it's still a
work in progress i'm making progress
with my kids
but i had to stop coaching them and i
had to just be
how's that feel i i i'm a hundred
percent
and but you're a counselor do you find
that you naturally move to the counselor
role
so they i wish i did they beat that out
of you in grad school
okay you cannot treat your they'll tell
you it's unethical and we will hope to
find out
and we'll take your license for me well
that's good if you counsel
your friends or your family you can't
have them as clients that's not your job
it's not your job to counsel your wife
or your kids
but i default to coach and what i
realized was
it was less of a moral failure and more
i i thought i had way more tools
and i thought that i've i've come to
liking baseball and fishing and hunting
because those are the three greatest
things and anyone who with a rational
brain oh and old punk bands too
anyone with a brain will understand that
those are the four things you should
spend your time and energy on and if
someone i love there yet well i'm right
but if i'm my kid i think
oh my son is super into 90s country
and i don't have a psychology for this
yeah
and that's right i thought you know what
i just haven't explained it right
i went and bought cds we would take road
trips where i
i found myself trying to convince a
nine-year-old that he should be liking
this over this
and it's an exact same that's that's
what i was describing is that they may
just have they don't react the way to me
that i wanted them to react to me and
all of a sudden i'm projecting my needs
onto them
what turns into like well have you heard
that or heard the the
so it goes better i know we were gonna
talk about parenting but
uh but you know it's hard that's this
show man it's really hard
it's the hardest thing i'll ever do i
disagree i'm i'm willing
to say that no it's it'll be harder
things
so i'm interested i'm not convinced of
that but that's okay how do you
you find yourself coaching my kids are
we talking about find yourself
yeah oh jeez we're still there what is
what is your
backpedal mechanism how do you when you
catch yourself
oh uh i'll give you an example that's
good yeah
the other day i um
my son was you and i were talking about
this i
he said hey dad can i take some of your
fancy lures to the creek
me and his buddies we're gonna catch
some fish i said dude there's no chance
you can't catch any fish there none
zero it's two feet of water and he's
like okay
but we're gonna go fishing can i borrow
these
and then i realized my data isn't gonna
solve this problem i've been fishing a
thousand i've been fishing five thousand
times
you will not catch fish in there with
that lure
hey but dad can i you know what yes
great and if you lose them you're paying
for them yeah
and then i get a text on my phone a few
hours later for my wife and for me to
let you know that you were raw
and they caught a fish and it made me it
made me happy
i was excited but i thought my default
setting was oh that's so awesome i
thought
oh that's a lot of therapy because i
would have been pissed
like this guy's caught a fish and then i
would be mad at myself and i would have
been ashamed and i would have been
grumpy in the spiral and what yeah so my
back pedal
is becoming i wish i could say i do it
all the time but it's getting to the
point where
now i'm empathizing instead of trying to
equip
ah okay you know that's the coach you
want to do you mean with the heart
not with more info yeah it's well i'm
empathizing two ways number one i first
go did i do something like that when i
was that age
probably probably sometimes worse yeah
um that's the first thing
the second thing is is that uh i want
them to
feel that while i'm not thrilled with
their actions
i'm crazy about them yeah i um
you talk about the bible on this show
yeah you talk about whatever you want to
on this there's a
there's a well known whether you've ever
been in church or not
if you've ever heard the parable the
prodigal son look it up and i've been in
church my whole life as we were talking
and recently i saw something in that
parable that i've never seen before
so when the prodigal comes back from in
a place of shame he's coming back he's
lost everything he's filthy he's nasty
he's been eating with the pigs he comes
back and the way the parable is told
that jesus tells it
is the father sees the sun coming from
him far off
and he's excited and he welcomes him
right and and i kind of always
just kind of glossed over the rest of
the story because i've always liked
that's awesome
the father was glad his son was back
but nowhere in the parable does he say
come here give me a hug
i told you so i knew this was going to
happen but i'm glad you're safe
there was none of that in fact it's the
next action
so the father does two things one he
goes to the road to meet his son and he
sticks his arms out and welcomes the son
you're welcome but it's the next step
that i've never seen before
he goes go prepare the finest dinner
we're doing a party that's next level
it's not
unconditional love is your welcome back
right
i don't even know what you call that
we're
celebrating that you're alive and that
you're back we're throwing
a party you burned my money you
embarrassed me in the community
you split my family up and i'm so glad
let's go have chips in case you're so
glad you're home yeah like
so i was just telling my wife that this
is i've not shared this with anybody
i was just like that's the part that's
so hard
about parenting the love is there yeah
but i never saw the other part
which is i'm gonna show you crazy
reckless crazy reckless grace
and redemption i think it's redemption i
think it's one thing if the father hugs
the dude and goes hey let's go get you a
shower
they threw a party that kid goes from
shame to
what is going on here i don't know dude
i'm running with this oh here's what i
love
that stands up theologically that's the
way well here's what i love about it
is it's the person who was spurned who
went first
yeah the person in power went first and
often
it wasn't about him he wasn't worried
about what everybody thought there's
where i struggle
i get so hung up in my kid's behavior or
whatever like what are people going to
think about me it's like would you stop
it
it's not about you you bonehead it's
about them i think the father was going
i don't care what anybody thinks
even with his other son in the back
going hey what about me yeah uncle
larry's going i wouldn't have done that
you know uncle larry was in the back of
it but i don't know about this i've had
him in my boy
i kicked his butt yeah don't you think
of course
and yeah and we solved it with
connection
all right i'm gonna draw you nearer than
you could even imagine
right that's so i'm that's trying to be
my back pedal
so you're you're leaning into
yeah as a dad you go first man and it's
isn't it crazy i do that too can i
now i'm thinking about it sometimes i
look at my 11 year old and think
well you did this so when you're ready
to take the first step
it's like what an idiot man caught
myself recently 11.
caught myself recently and it just a
normal wasn't a big thing this is not a
major fire yeah it was just normal
parent stuff normal
disobedience kind of stuff or just bad
decision
and i caught my i literally said it but
i couldn't get the words back
and it was i'm sorry i failed you
yeah yeah i said that
my kid was like literally like what woke
me up was my kid was like
no you didn't my kid
we're talking about teens that are like
they don't even know they have no sense
and he was like
uh no you didn't it was me
and that's the issue there well
dude i didn't know we weren't about fear
i was talking about some tissue
when i got home and i told my son i'm
so excited i was wrong i y'all are
really impressed good job catching fish
and he gave me a hug oh yeah but
modeling for him
here's what it looks like to say i was
wrong i will tell you
some of the biggest breakthroughs for me
uh is watching my kids respond to me
going i totally blew it
yeah yeah sorry like i i don't even have
a good excuse
i blew it here yeah and i can't think of
a greater gift other than
food and water and treating our spouses
with dignity
yeah it's a great point by the way this
is good this is good for your marriage
it is for your parent
i mean this is the same kind of stuff
here so it's a good at workplace when
you go in oh yeah i go into dave and say
hey man i said this i didn't i didn't
mean to say it this way i'm sorry
and i mean i can't tell you how many
times i've had to literally
walk into a co-worker with a plate of
steaming crow
cut it up in front of him and go i'm
going to eat this in front of you
i got to tell you but it's liberating
because here's the whole thing let's
circle back to some stuff here yeah
for people that are watching here and
because you're took the people that feel
like they failed
beyond repair that is such bs there's no
that you didn't fail
i mean you may have failed but you're
not beyond reducing you you failed yeah
you screwed up bad but you're not beyond
redundancy you learned to eat the crow
and you learned to see
redemption on the other side of eating
crow
i'm telling you the greatest lessons are
when we're willing to just
eat that dirty bit that's when i can
untether my ego from
i it's not that i have to be perfect
it's the image of having to be perfect
if i can unhook from that
you're free forcing to confront your
failure makes it hurt
even more than you already thought like
you know what i'm saying
it's enough for you to go oh geez i just
really screwed up and hurt somebody
that's your own recognition but then
when you got to go to them
it's like that's like a screwdriver in
an open wound
am i right yeah it hurts to own it to
them but here's what happens
to me as you know it leads to healing
it's freedom yeah
but but it's also like i don't want to
feel that much more
yeah so people assume because you are
a syndicated radio host you've spoken in
front of
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people that's so
impressive right just saw you with a
with the former president the other day
um what do they assume
when's the time you have screwed up
can you be more specific yeah
professionally because here's the thing
like
i i think there's a perception that oh
once you're there wherever
people imagine there is that um
you've got that skill down like once
you're a mechanic and you learn how to
put a change of tire you change the tire
right you don't mess that up yeah it
depends on what kind of screw-ups we're
talking about if you had an awesome okay
let's do a live event have you had an
awesome live event
screwing up whoopsie yeah
um live event whoopsie dude you've
interviewed
yeah hundreds um nothing comes to mind
but i'll tell you this james and kelly
are over there i mean
early on like when dave came up with
this idea one day
that person i wasn't even an official
personality but they were gonna host a
radio show
and and so you know we had to do this
and this all this pressure and it's this
second largest show in the world i mean
the chair felt like i was sitting in
john bunyan's lazy boy right the first
time we did it
so we go on i don't know james it might
have been
four or five months in and i had just
started my fledgling podcast
and i just was live on the air one day
rolling along and i gave out my full
phone number and said the ken coleman
show
not a big deal now that we look back on
it a very understandable mistake because
i had started a daily show the time
but you would have i do listen to me i
was
mortified because this is the biggest
show
i mean this is this is a massive show
this is a legend seat i'm sitting i
don't even belong in the room right
and i accidentally just said my phone
number and my name
and there's new people coming in all the
time and i just felt like well that was
one
small thing but it felt really huge so
that was a big uh oh
uh the first time i did that i was
mortified yeah
james could tell you i mean i probably
was eight shades of white and he was
worried and
and some people make mistakes at work 30
people find out
you make that mistake in i'll tell you
this i've
i am such a control freak and i didn't
realize i was a control freak until
recently because i'm not a detail guy
okay i'm not organized and i'm not
detailed okay anybody that knows
what are you what are you a control
freak about perception image okay
image image and perception control
freak man want everybody to like me want
everybody to think that i've got what it
takes that i belong blah blah blah
blah blah blah okay so so i was on my
own for a long time
lone wolf so so when you're not bouncing
into people
yeah well just yeah yeah my own show on
my own in atlanta i didn't have a team
gotcha so i come to ramsey and you got i
think i joined the team when there was
like 700
people or something 800 people so i just
started working with people
and that some of that stuff flared up
and i've i've unfortunately ripped
people's heads off
oh god because i felt like they they
they
either didn't respect or didn't you know
what i'm saying it was all about respect
yeah
you didn't understand i can't believe
you'd say that or you'd ask that or
just that kind of stuff just feeling
like ken freaking coleman
not from that standpoint of an arrogance
thing but a
what like you don't think i know what
i'm doing on this like
that's what i mean like it wasn't an
arrogance it may have come it
come across that way but it was it's
from a bad place of control gotcha you i
can't believe you think this or that you
even ask that or whatever or i had a
high standard
and there i would help hold people to
standards that weren't realistic
you understand what i'm saying yeah
totally so some of that stuff
that i've really blown it professionally
where i've just been super intense with
co-workers
um and that's tough because the irony of
that is
the people please are the unhealthy
people pleasers what caused the flare up
and then you flare up and whack somebody
on the head you're not pleasing that in
a moment of not being healthy then you
feel even worse
just spins that sucker you can break
that down better than i can well it ends
up in the toilet bowl right it just
spins faster and faster and faster
yeah so until you get healthy on that
yeah and you realize that
you're allowing stuff to trigger you
that has nothing to do with what these
folks are doing
nothing yeah yeah yeah uh so anyway i
remember the first meeting i was here so
i'm i'm hyper sensitive about
my appearance and you are oh my gosh one
of the first me and that's that's
childhood stuff back when i was a kid
i think it's news to me as well this is
fascinating i only sat in
the very first one we did a photo shoot
and they walk me in a room and there's a
giant flat screen and
there's 30 people they're like this is
my favorite ken i may have told you this
there's somebody walks up and they're
looking at a picture of me it's like a
five foot
picture of me and they're scrolling
through them scrolling through them and
you hear people go no
no oh gosh no no i can get that and i'm
sitting there going
what i know but somebody says this me
everybody
oh this one's perfect look how he's
standing look at these clothes
ah this would be perfect if it weren't
for his face
and i remember thinking wow guys that's
my i can't change that part and
everybody laughed it was funny
but i had to get over it man because i
was so sensitive about it
that that's very similar time for years
to perceive the sensitivity to that and
if that triggers that
you know better i mean i'm talking to
the psychologist here so some of that
stuff
having to learn how to uh process that
and understand that that that's coming
from some place
yeah that's what i'm bringing it to them
yeah yeah so often
when somebody calls into the show
they'll tell me hey there's a presenting
issue
and one of the things i'm always looking
for is threads like
how far is this thread go yeah one of
the
most common questions i i'll ask is walk
me through
what home look like when you're a kid
yeah so a quick
thread what's something you learn from
your dad
that is passed through ken that you are
so excited to pass along like what's
something you still carry with you
something you carry with you well i was
talking to my dad this morning
yeah and so the easy answer to that
question is
he taught me the most valuable lesson
that any human has ever taught me
yeah um and it uh
it has been with me since i was a
seven-year-old soccer player dang dude
seven years seven years old so i'm a
little guy now imagine me at seven i
look like i was four
did you have a humongous head and tiny
little legs uh nothing about me
humongous i think everything was
she had a huge hit everything everything
on me is like a running q-tip
i'm just small guy small guy there it is
and so i'm showing up to play
in a six to eight-year-old league or six
seven to ten something i don't know i'm
the smallest kid on the team okay
now this was back in the day this is in
the 80s so everybody didn't get a trophy
and there was no equal playing time i'm
serious
i remember those days i'm not trying to
old school all of a sudden folks i'm
just telling you that was my reality
come on kelly yeah right
so if you're listening to get equal
playing time in little league if you
weren't good just
you never played you sat over in the
corner of the dugout looking through the
chain link
eating big league chew and there'd be
one coach should go to the other coach
and go
should we put him in and run up to right
field nope one inning yeah yeah
yeah this was the reality i remember so
here i am little kenny coleman
i look like i'm four i'm seven i want to
play soccer
i really am pretty decent at it but my
coach fred cerbal never forget his name
no wound at all
nothing there at all he doesn't play me
you're like that guy on billy madison
he doesn't play me and i don't know if
this is two or three games in the season
fast forward one day on the way home
from the game i'm in the back seat
my dad's driving just the two of us i'm
crying
he notices i'm crying it's the old
conversation through the rearview mirror
oh yeah our eyes are meeting i'm sobbing
what's wrong bud i croak through tears
something along the lines of i just want
to play or i'm not playing something
like that
he looks at me and he says hang in there
your time will come four words
your time will come now he then goes on
to say
you're small you'll eventually get a
little bit bigger a little bit faster
coach will give you a chance and you're
going to
play and you will score goals you
prophesize if you will over me
came true yeah two years later i'm the
oldest in the league i make the travel
select team i'm scoring lots of goals
life is glorious there you go cue the
john mellencamp
glory days right so that lesson stayed
with me
in my 20s when i was trying to get into
politics and i got in it stayed with me
in my 30s and i don't have time to
unpack it because we got to go i'm sure
but
um even as i sit here today on the
precipice of 47
yeah about the launch
probably my most important massive book
yeah
uh an assessment other things massive
pressure
because dave's giving us a platform and
we're actually helping people
and i want to do more i want to do it
faster
your time will come and he taught me
patience
while persisting very difficult thing to
do and you
i'm trying to put myself in so that's
like in the driver's seat of that car
yeah i bet your dad's heart was ripped
out like look
at your son crying and thinking i can't
fix this i got a seven-year-old back
there whose world has been shattered
he wants to just want to play he just
wants to play man
yeah and and for him to have those words
your time will come and um
i'm gonna i believe i'll write a parable
style book on that message one day
can i tell you the most important thing
i've ever learned my old man my dad um
man very similar similar playing
baseball
and i've always been a big kid and so i
had
an opposite thing but i had a rough
season and
i was good out in the field but i was
really struggling to play and he said
something if you can hit the ball
they will find a place on the field for
you yeah and i remember thinking
man if i can put the time in because i
wasn't practicing i was running around
my buddies
but it was a statement of if if if you
can play
yeah that's it and it was a i i felt a
sense of
the ball's in your court yeah um like
the
universe has smiled on you you're a big
kid you want to put to work
and i've always had that hey i'm not i'm
not getting this job i didn't get this
promotion
then i'm probably not ready for it right
i'm not there yet
and for all the dads out there right
wrong or indifferent
and those little those little those
moments he had no idea
stay with you he had no idea how
profound that was until many years later
i told him and he was in tears
and to be honest with you there's
nothing profound there it's profound
but it's four words yeah so speaking
life into your kids man that's what i'm
saying man
doesn't matter how it sounds mom doesn't
matter how it sounds dad
just absorb it just throw your heart out
all right man hey dude thanks for coming
to hang out on the show dude this is fun
you're awesome
thank you you're great um so
every show we end with some song lyrics
i'm gonna do a first on this [ __ ]
a second i let mcconaughey do it and i'm
gonna let ken coleman do it
what do we got what am i doing so i just
put me up against my contacts
before the show no chance i asked you
before the show
what your oh yeah so long would be
greatest song of all time
and for only the second time i'm gonna
let you read these
oh you picked them give the
why who why and read
you know the verse verse and the chorus
you asked there you asked me this
question
and i immediately decided i'm going to
go with the first thing that comes to my
mind and i'm so glad i did and i thought
about it later and it's unquestionable
my favorite song of all time garth
brooks the dance
gold garth 90s country man because he's
garth first
of all garth um but the lyrics so good
man
the dance i'm reading this looking back
it's all i can do not to sing it but i
know james will turn the mic off but
please sing it please sing again
mcconaughey sang it
did he did it the the problem
is is garth is so unique yeah this
song's so great i'll dishonor the very
thing but anyway looking back he's a
poet let's
let's do it looking back on the memory
of the dance we shared
beneath the stars above for a moment all
the world was right
how could i have known that you'd ever
say goodbye
and now i'm glad i didn't know the way
it all would end
the way it all would go and this is my
favorite line our lives
are better left a chance i could have
missed the pain
but i'd have had to miss
dude thanks for being here man you're
choking me get me out of here
hey thanks so much ken coleman go to
kidcoleman.com you can listen to the ken
coleman show you can follow him on the
internets at ken coleman
make sure you pick up his brand new book
please from paycheck to purpose
my kids need shoes i'm your kid's shoes
are awesome
and when we park next to each other i
feel it but it's good man it's good
hey buy the book for yourself buy the
book for your friends and family
hey thank you for joining us right here
on the dr john dolone show
you